c'est le plus grand rendez vous pour les
scouts du monde entier quelle que soit
leur confession et se réunissent tous
les quatre ans c'est leur job doré et
cette année pour la première fois depuis
20 ans il avait lieu en europe près
d'amsterdam chez les boisserie et hervé
pozzo à l'entrée du jamboree ils font
flotter les drapeaux du monde entier car
ils viennent car ils viennent du monde
entier pendant dix jours ils ne vivent
que dans un seul pays
celui du scoutisme une grande colonie de
vacances aux activités multiples aux
rencontres variées et aux échanges en
tout genre bienvenue au stand du troc ou
les cours de l'écusson et du badge
fluctuent au gré des rencontres
nous avons une collection complète de
badges et on possède tous les badges
hong kong
mais on aime aussi être ensemble ça a
partagé avec les quelques trente mille
personnes réunies ici et on adore camper
les scouts de brunei n'échangeront
cependant pas leur uniforme contre les
kilts des écossais il préfère la culture
italienne car des différences il en
reste à chacun son culte à chacun son
organisation de la plus stricte à la
plus libérale tout le monde se
retrouvant sous une bannière au message
très rassembleur le futur c'est
maintenant au soir tombant certains
écopent de la corvée photo car tous les
groupes veulent poser devant le monument
spécialement érigé pour ce jamboree dans
un des campements français c'est lors de
la vaisselle
la tâche ne fait pas peur pendant toute
l'année ils ont multiplié les petits
boulots pour se payer ce voyage et ce
voisinage avec vous et que bien entendu
c'est surtout les gens autour d'un autre
allemand portugais et les mauvais
plaisants
ces courriels auraient acquis jours sans
arrêt vous dans vos courriels voilà
c'est cool
la gigue le yes et jean petit qui danse
tous les soirs
chacun présente un spectacle de son pays
hier soir les français ont donc tenté
d'apprendre la gigue aux américains aux
suédois au sénégal et mêmes aux coréens